do you worry about bots on the internet
given given these ideas given how
exciting they are do you worry about
bots on Twitter being not the the stupid
boss that we see now with the cryptobots
but the Bots that might be out there
actually that we don't see that they're
interacting in interesting ways so this
kind of system feels like it should be
able to pass the I'm not a robot click
button whatever
um which you actually understand how
that test works I don't quite like
there's there's a there's a check box or
whatever that you click it's presumably
tracking oh I see like Mouse movement
and the timing and so on yeah so exactly
this kind of system we're talking about
should be able to pass that so yeah what
do you feel about
um Bots that are language models Plus
have some interact ability and are able
to tweet and reply and so on do you
worry about that world
uh yeah I think it's always been a bit
of an arms race uh between sort of the
attack and the defense uh so the attack
will get stronger but the defense will
get stronger as well our ability to
detect that how do you defend how do you
detect how do you know that your karpate
account on Twitter is is human
how'd you approach that like if people
were claim you know uh how would you
defend yourself in the court of law that
I'm a human
um this account yeah at some point I
think uh it might be I think the society
Society will evolve a little bit like we
might start signing digitally signing uh
some of our correspondents or you know
things that we create uh right now it's
not necessary but maybe in the future it
might be I do think that we are going
towards the world where we share
we share the digital space with uh AIS
synthetic beings yeah and uh they will
get much better and they will share our
digital realm and they'll eventually
share our Physical Realm as well it's
much harder uh but that's kind of like
the world we're going towards and most
of them will be benign and awful and
some of them will be malicious and it's
going to be an arms race trying to
detect them so I mean the worst isn't
the AIS the worst is the AIS pretending
to be human so mine I don't know if it's
always malicious there's obviously a lot
of malicious applications but yeah it
could also be you know if I was an AI I
would try very hard to pretend to be
human because we're in a human world
yeah I wouldn't get any respect as an AI
yeah I want to get some love and respect
I don't think the problem is intractable
people are people are thinking about the
proof of personhood yes and uh we might
start digitally signing our stuff and we
might all end up having like uh
yeah basically some some solution for
proof of personhood it doesn't seem to
be intractable it's just something that
we haven't had to do until now but I
think once the need like really starts
to emerge which is soon I think what
people think about it much more so but
that too will be a race because
um obviously you can probably uh spoof
or fake the the the proof of personhood
so you have to try to figure out how to
probably I mean it's weird that we have
like Social Security numbers and like
passports and stuff
it seems like it's harder to fake stuff
in the physical space than the residual
space it just feels like it's going to
be very tricky very tricky to out
um because it seems to be pretty low
cost fake stuff what are you gonna put
an AI in jail for like trying to use a
fake fake personhood proof I mean okay
fine you'll put a lot of AIS in jail but
there'll be more ai's arbitrary like
exponentially more the cost of creating
a bot is very low
uh unless there's some kind of way
to track accurately
like you're not allowed to create any
program without showing uh tying
yourself to that program like you any
program that runs on the internet you'll
be able to uh Trace every single human
program that was the laws of that
program right yeah maybe you have to
start declaring when uh you know we have
to start drawing those boundaries and
keeping track of okay uh what our
digital entities versus
human entities and uh what is the
ownership of human entities and digital
entities and uh
something like that
um
I don't know but I think I'm optimistic
that this is uh this is uh possible and
at some in some sense we're currently in
like the worst time of it because
um all these Bots suddenly have become
very capable but we don't have defenses
yet built up as a society and but I
think uh that doesn't seem to be
intractable it's just something that we
have to deal with it seems weird that
the Twitter but like really crappy
Twitter Bots are so numerous like is it
so I presume that the engineers at
Twitter are very good
so it seems like what I would infer from
that
uh is it seems like a hard problem
they're probably catching all right if I
were to sort of steal them on the case
it's a hard problem and there's a huge
cost to uh false positive
to to removing a post by somebody that's
not a bot that's creates a very bad user
experience so they're very cautious
about removing so maybe it's uh and
maybe the boss are really good at
learning what gets removed and not
such that they can stay ahead of the
removal process very quickly my
impression of it honestly is uh there's
a lot of looking for it I mean yeah just
that's what I it's not subtle it's my
impression of it it's not so but you
have to yeah that's my impression as
well but it feels like maybe you're
seeing the the tip of the iceberg maybe
the number of bots is in like the
trillions and you have to like
just it's a constant assault of bots and
yeah you yeah I don't know
um you have to still man the case
because the boss I'm seeing are pretty
like obvious I could write a few lines
of code that catch these Bots I mean
definitely there's a lot of belonging
fruit but I will say I agree that if you
are a sophisticated actor you could
probably create a pretty good bot right
now
um you know using tools like gpts
because it's a language model you can
generate faces that look quite good now
uh and you can do this at scale and so I
think um yeah it's quite plausible and
it's going to be hard to defend